قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
واشنطن ستواصل استخدام المسيرات في البحر
الاسود لضمان المصالح الامريكيه وتمكين
اوكرانيا من الدفاع عن نفسها ونشر
البنتاجون صورا قال انها عمليه اعتراض غير
امن نفذتها مقاتله روسيه للمسيره
الامريكيه وتحدث مسؤولون امريكيون عن ان
القرار باعتراضها صدر عن الكرملين ونقلت
شبكه سي ان ان عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
البنتاغون يجري تقييما لمسارات المسيرات
الامريكيه في اجواء البحر الاسود اتبحث
الوزاره طرقا بديله لتفادي المقاتلات
الروسيه وتجنب التصعيد مع روسيا فضلا عن
الاعتماد على الاقمار الصناعيه في جمع
المعلومات
قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ديمتريديف فانه يجب تتبع حركه الطائرات
المسيره في المجال الجوي الذي هو جزء من
اراضينا وسيادتنا واضاف في تغريده على
موقع تيليجرام ان الامريكيين فقدوا عقولهم
تماما وان الوقوف معهم خطا رغم الحاجه
للاتصالات العسكريه على حد التعبير
هذا وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه انه اذا كانت
واشنطن مهتمه باستئناف العمل بمعاهده
ستارت فعليها الابتعاد عن اوهام هزيمه
روسيا واضافت ان خرق الولايات المتحده
معاهده ستارت اعطى روسيا اسبابا لتعليقها
وقالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا ان روسيا لم تغلق قنوات التواصل مع
الولايات المتحده واضافت في مؤتمر صحفي ان
روسيا لا تسعى الى المواجهه
نعتبر من المهم ابقاء قنوات الاتصال
مفتوحه وهي كذلك نحن لا نسعى الى المواجهه
وندعم التعاون البراغماتي الذي يصب في
مصالح الشعوب بلدينا علما اننا نجيد حمايه
هذه المصالح